still just uh
yeah maybe just not switching gears so
okay let's see it's all about speed we
will tell we will be able to tell a lot
over the next 10 moves uh just who can
play the quickest who can go bang bang
bang
with their moves and
okay deep four uh deep uh deepon opening
queen's pawn opening first time we've
seen that from magnus today at least
and okay using this move the move he
used in game six of the world
championship match to win that marathon
battle against the pontiac um this is
really interesting decision making from
magnus and okay black pushing a pawn
white castling this is exactly what we
saw yesterday in one of uh the games
between these two until this last pawn
move really rare decision just backing
up the center with the pawn by magnus
i've never seen this one before in my
life and i've been playing this the
whole time as white pretty much so
interesting decision magnus the first
one to make duda think and dude also
backs up his pawns
and do you think our whole idea is now
to start pushing some pawns challenging
black superiority and center or maybe
play a longer game okay well he's gone
for immediate action i like this i like
this idea because you know black really
can't capture the porn uh that's been
offered up for grabs and instead decides
to capture a pawn in the middle of the
board
and i'm expecting i would say knight
takes born um or is it porn
yeah white can actually has a choice of
two pawns to capture i would maybe
capture the pawn on the fifth rank
because that just opens things up even
quicker it's not clear the pawn that has
just moved where the white wants to take
that with his knight with his pawn uh i
would capture the other one and magnus
did react okay he does go and capture
with the knight uh a bit of discomfort
there seemingly from magnus he didn't
make a quick decision he spent about 20
seconds on that last move and that's not
unusual from him in blitz i've played
him hundreds of times in blitz and he's
normally making these decisions
instantly it feels to me as if magnus is
a bit uncertain and again pausing he's
got two choices he can take back this
night with the queen or with a pawn he
should have planned this on the last
move instead just taking another 20
seconds or so and uh okay still a
balanced position but magnus may be just
struggling to switch into this blitz
mode
okay bringing out pieces due to castles
very sensible we'll see things speed up
now trade of pawns in the center
dude see how he's reacting instantly to
these big decisions which pieces to
trade
magnus doing a much slower version of
that so okay
only bishops now on the board all the
knights have disappeared for blitz i
think both sides will breathe a sigh of
relief the knights are so tricky and
blitz but white has a small advantage
yeah i was going to say active queen
more active queen and something to
nibble on on the left the right side of
the ball sorry the left side of the
board
you know and uh white's plan is simple
you know there's one open line and he
wants to put a rook along the sea line
and uh just maximize his forces
and also if you look at the two central
pawns white has an isolated pawn black
has an isolated pawn but white's bishops
are pointing towards those pawns blacks
are purely defending and okay an offer
of a queen trade magnus i'm pretty sure
we'll say no if you trade the queens off
you lose some ammunition for later in
the battle and uh if the queen's come
off i think we'll just see a draw yeah
so magnus needs to keep the queens on
black's queen very passive so don't
trade off an active piece on the side of
the board for a passive one
for me it's tempting just to march the
queen two squares up the board you know
there's a hole there why not just occupy
it yeah that would be very logical you
could also make an argument for just
sliding back on the diagonal one square
is magnus going to get ambitious with
his queen
he's still playing a bit slowly compared
to dude at least
uh is he still in rapid mode
this is blitz now he needs to decide
he's gonna keep the queens on that's a
given he can't trade them off
unless he's just not feeling it unless
he wants to bring the match to
armageddon well he could also take the
queens off okay he does
push the queen two squares up the board
i did wonder whether maybe he could
maybe play a little bit ambitiously with
the queens off the board but no i don't
think he could and i think doodle will
keep trying to insist on a queen trade
black's queen now blocks up her rook uh
blocks up the top rank so the queen the
black queen could just slide two squares
to the left off a queen trade very
sensible very logical dude are now
pausing but he's got 30 seconds extra on
the clock the time we're going to keep
an eye on it because it's going to
decide this game for sure or it's going
to decide the final of the charity
carpent okay playing the most logical
move offering a queen trade again
passive piece of active pete is peace is
always a good exchange so magnus i'm
sure he's going to retreat his queen no
way is magnus going to trade the queens
off now
because also that would help black's
rooks occupy this sea the sea line the
only open file that ivanka was talking
about
okay white queen has to retreat magnus
has to decide quickly he's a minute down
on the clock yeah if this goes to
armageddon i think duda is the big
favorite because magnus is just not
looking quick right now no he's not
looking confident at all no he's not
it's somehow he
hasn't quite recovered from what
happened in game two
and uh now like you say he's taking his
time it is quite a simple position you
know the pawn structure is almost
well in the middle of the board it's
kind of symmetrical it's pretty clear
not too many minor pieces it's just
about controlling those open files yep
the bishops kind of balance each other
out whites are slightly better than
blacks but it's all about the major
pieces if the rooks will disappear if
the queens disappear dead draw i don't
think black can ever hope to be better
but
it just depends whether white can keep
the rooks on keep the queens on it's not
going to be an easy task
well another great thing about tie
breaks is that we have more time to uh
to get our money for our fundraiser for
unicef youssef from slovakia just
donated eleven dollars
um yeah we definitely want to fundraise
more money for the important work unicef
is doing and also a big thank you to all
our um supporting partners all our uh
participants in the play magnus charity
challenge everyone who has
participated in our fundraiser okay we
have a move we have a move and that one
cost duda quite a lot of time and also
it's the most natural move in the
position black's queen now kind of
blocking off white queen from entering
and uh here we go all the rooks looking
at each other challenging
uh for this open sea line white giving
his king some breathing space black is
likely to do the same
uh the black king okay there we go duda
you don't want to leave your king with
no breathing space especially in blitz
there'll be all sorts of tricks against
your king all these background
checkmates and is it a good idea okay
well he's actually improved the bishop
you know put it in the middle of the
board
[Music]
i i mean it just feels like a move a
nice move but uh okay and duda kicking
away the queen and i was curious as to
whether you know this was actually a
good plan by duda because it does mean
that the contact point between white's
army and the black army has suddenly
drawn closer and there you can see
magnus just uh breaking through on the
left side and dude a tiny almost
imperceptible shake of his head there um
he's not so happy suddenly this is a
magnus type of position again
white has a small advantage because of
his superior bishops and white holds the
key to the queen side ivanka you looked
surprised for a second yeah and i was
just wondering whether the bishop that
uh at the minute was looking at not too
many
pawns could actually step back and start
targeting the weak pawn that is going to
appear on b5 yep so white's light
squared bishop in front of his king it's
a bit redundant right now no real work
for it just staring at a well-defended
pawn so ivanka is expecting it to drop
back in a moment but first big decision
queen trade
can i avoid this dude really trying to
insist uh throughout this middle game on
getting the queens off uh end games
usually favor magnus but the problem is
there are no knights no real imbalances
if the queens come off i fear we're
headed towards a draw so can magnus keep
the queens on it's not easy maybe the
white queen can just slide back to the
left just to the a2 square keep yourself
nice and safe avoiding any trades and
then ivanka's idea of dropping white's
light squared bishop back hitting the
black queen
on a different diagonal so
okay magnus still hesitant yes we'll
remove 23. okay he trades a set of rooks
first we'll move 23 24 but
down to two minutes for both sides i
think if these two just played a blitz
game without having played the kind of
rapid play games earlier today they
would have been much quicker than this
and we've seen a trade of queens
actually
and uh well he did uh maneuver his like
square bishop to attack the pawn so now
duda has to deal with that either he
defends or he goes on the counter attack
and he pushes forward with the pawn
magnus quickly moving the bishop to
cover the key c2 square very nice move
there from magnus stopping the black
rook from ever intruding into white's
half of the board now all of black's
squares for his rook are controlled on
the sea line or white has full control
there but white's rook cannot be
controlled by black's pieces so white's
rook can jump in and get active at any
moment it's not easy for black to do the
same okay dude fighting for space on the
other flank uh in the opening middle
game this would have been very very
weakening the black king would be very
open but queens have disappeared so this
is fine it totally feels like like this
weakening though i think it's fine i
think dude had to try this at some point
because otherwise he would have been uh
suffocated almost for space we had some
pre-moves yeah some pre-moves and white
capturing a porn duda had assumed that
white would capture it so he took back
with his own pawn instantly he'd made
that move happen before it even uh
occurred on the board and look at this
the rook coming in
yeah maybe you'll be proved right ivanka
maybe the black king will be the target
it feels like magnus is trying to
somehow break his rook across the board
if you can pick up the white rook and
plant it next to the black king on the
h8 square that's actually checkmate so
maybe magnus is just trying to plot a
path for that white rook
meanwhile the black coat has to guard
the eighth rank now just to prevent any
checkmates
and the white king freita free to wander
yeah white's king is very very safe no
attacking pieces around it and actually
this is the key move from magnus i was
underestimating maybe the threats
against black's king because i thought
black could pick up the f-pawn and kick
away white's bishop from the center of
the board but that's not possible
white's rook is actually eyeing up
black's light square bishop so uh yeah
black's a bit frozen black's a bit stuck
not clear what to do and
despite uh me mentioning it was a bit
slow from both sides earlier magnus is
sped up he's quickened the pace
and i think he's made the last five or
six moves and only spent 10 seconds
doing that
so uh duder under one minute for the
first time
can he react this is again not a doo-doo
type of position he very rarely thrives
in these types of
kind of drier end games where he's
purely defending
and okay he locks down the pawn
structure on the right side of the board
but that's committal as well yeah i
think he primarily did that to release
the dark square bishop because that one
the dark square bishop was kind of stuck
on its square and now the king joins in
the action
and uh it's time for white's king as
well to do the same
so magnus is keeping his king nice and
safe black's rook just hinting at
getting active it wants to bring itself
down maybe to the second rank to go for
some white pawns but you've got to be
really careful if the black rook ever
moves white's rook is going to go to the
eighth rank with a deadly check
so okay magnus keeping black's king
honest keeping black's king tied down to
one of its bishops
and dude are trying to evict this white
rook this one's still very tense it
feels like magnus is making progress but
you still need some tangible you need to
win a pawn or you need something
in order to win this game
dude just going back and forth just
trying to just fix the blockade
maybe it's time just to improve the king
get the king into the action put it in
the center
and uh see maybe whether the king can
kind of snake its way around and i'm
thinking of putting it on the b3 square
yeah white's king not really doing too
much where it previously stood so
ivanka's plan of marching the white king
all the way across the board black's
doing the same black's playing copycat
the black king's coming the white king
is coming who's king is going to
be better placed it feels like white's
king has the easier path white's king
could easily slide across black's king
if it moves too close to the okay he's
got to be careful if it moves too close
to the white rook might walk into some
deadly checks and duda 28 seconds left
is magnus playing for the win here
definitely and you can see the king is
coming and it wants to sit on the b3
square and once it's blockading the pawn
then that pawn is a target and this is
why duda just decides no he does not
want that king on the b3 square and
instead cuts it off yeah look at black's
pieces they're all kind of bunched
together right in the center but they're
passive black's light square bishop
can't move you might lose some pawns
black's dark square bishop can't move
you might lose some points black's rook
now forced to cut off the white king
what is black gonna do
nearly everything he touches might have
uh kind of bad consequences right now
yeah he just has to wait with his king i
mean there's not too many okay so he
moves his rook now your plan your anchor
the white king can continue its journey
towards the left yeah and uh yeah dude
shaking his head as well 15 seconds not
happy not happy but now magnus under a
minute on the clock and he has to take a
decision yeah and uh is he going to move
that white king he does he does very
natural it's the continuation of a
consistent plan very important in every
end game being consistent and okay duder
trying to maybe hint at trapping the
white rook also setting a nasty idea of
checkmate if the white king continues
its journey and goes to the b3 square
but magnus says no now a trade of light
squared bishops would favor magnus
because if black captures this bishop
white will just retreat the rock and
take a pawn dude oh he played that move
with just five six seconds left and the
black king is coming
wow dude trying to trap the white rook
really sneaky plan there
but uh okay now the black rook gets
active at least and
has magnus lost control yeah the bar is
down to zero he has 35 seconds left on
the clock and well this is why the
magnus has utilized the dark square
bishop just to control and protect those
pawns on the right dude i'm miraculously
just unraveling and that black rook is
super active now also this is really
reminiscent this endgame of duda's win
against magnus carlsen in the world cup
last year that one was also a dark
square bishop end game where black's
pawns were better than white's pawns
black's rook was more active than
white's rook so magnus has to be careful
not to lose control duda has beaten him
in this type of position you know i
think the game is actually soon going to
finish in a draw because i don't think
magnus has a good answer to the rook
shuffling between the e1 square and the
d1 square
yeah so white's king now under check if
you go to the right
you would have walked into black's rook
going to the left if you went to the
left you would have walked into a
black's root going the other way uh so
right now a bit of tension and black's
rook just keeping attacking pawns and
magnus leans back he knows as ivanka
says this game is destined to be a draw
no way to escape the checks no ways to
escape blacks rooks threats okay and
there's a big threat in the air and
that's to play bishop takes pawn
destabilizing the protection of the dark
square bishop while magnus plays for the
win he didn't want the draw there which
would have been the safe option duda
under
he made that move with two seconds left
duda shaking his head now magnus can go
and grab a pawn in the center with the
white rook
wow okay magnus is attacked the black
rook is magnus winning material oh look
at that the bar goes up magnus trick
duder there he's attacking the black
rook the black freak is about to fall
the black bishop under a threat as well
white is winning a piece here now you
can just take this black rook swing the
white rook over and
magnus takes the win duda blunded
in time horribly
game over magnus carlsen with the white
pieces the winner of the first blitz
game he is up by one point both players